Welcome to the special session on AI in cancer research
and care, what we've learned and what comes next.
Congratulations for your resilience. It's almost the end of the meeting.
And condolences for the people who have a talk tomorrow.
It's getting harder and harder to have a full room, but I really appreciate your
coming today.
Let me see.
Can you try to find the slide deck and put it on screen, please?
Perfect. Thank you very much.
So AI has been a really hot topic at the meeting,
whether it's in the plenary, special
sessions, or mini symposium. And so there are a few
key points that
kind of emerge from all those talks.
The one is that AI is spanning all kind of activities, whether it's
fundamental research, translational research, clinical application.
It's been the case in the past, but I think now we really reach a level
of maturity that was not seen before.
And the question is almost not so much like how do I build an AI model and
what can it do? But rather I deployed my AI models, how do I
properly assess and evaluate the performance of the model?
How do I optimize, maximize the benefit for the
researchers, the clinicians, and the patients?
So I think the field is maturing, which is a good
thing.
But there are a lot of challenges ahead, and we're probably going to discuss many
of those today, including how do I evaluate using benchmark?
How do I get the data I need to build the best AI model and deploy
it in the clinic?
Agentic AI, digital pathology, spatial biology, those are
really, really hot topic, and it keeps evolving, but I suspect
Agentic AI is going to be even more prominent in the next
iteration of the annual meeting. And so with
that, I'll just going to let the panel
discussion start.
Feel free to basically ask questions online if you
can, but you can also just go to the microphone.
We'll make sure we pause during the discussion so that you in the audience
can ask your most exciting question.
With that, I'll pass it to Christina, if you want to kick us off.
Yeah. So I think we've had really an amazing...
This is the most AI and data science we've had at an annual meeting.
I think it's actually very hard to keep up, and Ben has summarized some of
the topics that have emerged. But I personally think one
that
always comes up and is hard to show a presentation on because we
still lack data, is about the benchmarks.
And
we're in an era where it's easier and easier to train models, although we frankly
still lack much of the data we would like, multimodal, spatial,
and longitudinal. And I think as we think about
benchmarks, I kind of want to have a discussion with this group because I think if
we set the bar high to think about what we need for benchmarks, it can
help guide the discussion about what's going to be needed.
But the benchmarks that we need to evaluate the
performance of
our AI tools is one that needs more discussion,
and I think it varies pretty dramatically if it's for a clinical task where we
might have a binary outcome, a response, yes/no, a
pathologic complete response, yes/no,
versus in the biomedical discovery setting, where it's really
harder to say what is a gain. A gain in knowledge.
Have we learned some new biology?
Are we advancing in scientific reasoning which might
actually be the highest bar for these agentic frameworks.
So I guess I want to start, and I'm going to actually turn it to the clinician on
the panel as the starting point to say can you, Alex, maybe
share your perspective about what you think we need to be doing as a
community for benchmarks, and where are we at, and what is missing?
Great. Thank you. My name is Alex Pearson.
I'm a physician scientist at University of Chicago, and I'm a medical oncologist,
as well as a AI researcher. So, yeah,
one of the challenges I think for benchmarking has been that
for, say, the last decade, the value of data was so
high, right? I think if you had a data set that was
worth benchmarking on, it was probably worth
keeping to yourself to publish on, right?
To train a model on your own. And I think that
there are pros and cons, but I think that the relative value of
data are decreasing dramatically, effectively,
as more and more groups are aggregating very large data sets and making them
available. But oftentimes, I think, as many of the panel members know,
that those very large data sets are not
necessarily annotated with the quality endpoints that are most
important for us as clinicians. So
I think
that there is probably benchmarks,
as you alluded to, in a variety of different contexts.
We want to be able to have benchmarks that
render the clinical tasks that are most useful.
For example, diagnosing breast cancer on mammograms.
And I think we also need to develop some technical benchmarks that allow
us to compare against some of these very complex modeling frameworks,
like is the
manifold that's created in a foundation model well-posed to
adapt or to reflect the variations within data of a lot of
different types? And so,
I think that the
former may be actually even more challenging because
coming up with data sets with a true clinical gold
standard... can be very challenging.
Knowing that a patient hasn't ever recurred requires
decades of follow-up, potentially, and can be very time-consuming
and costly for that annotation process.
So I'm optimistic. I think that the
quality and volume of data that are becoming available to us is increasing
dramatically, public data.
And I would hope that there
are ongoing investments in the
building of that data, just like there are
increasing opportunities to publish those data with new journals now that are
just data set focused. So those are my thoughts.
So we shouldn't hoard our data.
No.
Right. Maybe would you like to introduce yourself?
Yeah, absolutely. Hi, everyone. I'm Danielle Bern 人 .
I'm a physician scientist as well.
I'm a radiation oncologist and AI researcher with a focus on
natural language processing
of the electronic health records.
So I completely agree with what's just been said about the importance of
benchmarking, and the need for new
technologic approaches for benchmarking,
especially as we are moving towards these really large
foundation models where we're not going to likely achieve
an interpretable model. In my opinion, I
think it's a reasonable trade-off to accept a
non-interpretable model as long as you have evidence that it provides
benefit. But that raises the bar and raises the need for benchmarks
more than ever before.
Another kind of challenge that I think about
with the newer class of models, which are both
very performant and also not trained for any
one particular task, and may not even be trained for a clinical task, but
we're still using to generalize the clinical tasks.
Like the general large language models that we're using to
draft patient notes with ambient documentation,
is that we can't rely on our previous, traditional machine learning
assumptions that we have this model that we've trained, we've
done supervised
learning on a labeled data set, so we can say, "We can
expect the performance will be X
in distribution data set that reflects the training data
set." And we can also expect that it's going to degrade as we
deploy it on increasingly different data sets.
Now, every data set is out of distribution, and when you
get to the zero few shot prompting
approaches, the
performance, it's hard to
know whether you can assume that your performance will be similar to
even related queries that you input previously, because
we don't completely know the interaction with how small changes in the
context and prompting might lead to very different
outputs. So it's really challenging.
I think another important point that has come up a few
times in a lot of the AI talks that I've seen at this ACR is
this idea that we have models that will do this type of reasoning that
might exceed what a single human is able to
oversee, which kind of gets to this question of
superhuman intelligence. Now, I think superhuman is used in a very
futuristic way, that we're going to have this AGI that's going to
outperform everything. But in some very narrow tasks, models really are
better than most humans. They are very good at
compressing knowledge and act as
very, in some cases, very robust information retrievers.
So a model can tell me the brand
generic names of drugs better than any physician I know is able
to do. But how do you oversee something like that?
I think that's where we get into similar to this technical question of we need
newer methods to
oversee the reasoning pathways of these models
and oversee their stepwise actions, because it's
easier to oversee stepwise actions than it might be to oversee the final
output.
That's great. And maybe we'll turn it to you, Charlotte, and maybe you can speak to
some of the also basic sort of fundamental discovery
science that requires different flavors of benchmarks.
So I'm Charlotte Brunner. I'm an assistant professor at EPFL, and so I'm actually
jointly affiliated with School of Computer Science and School of
Life Sciences or the Cancer Institute.
And so very much on the benchmarking, I think what we are trying now
in cancer biology, biology in general, is to mirror the
success that we've seen in vision and in language.
And I think we shouldn't forget the somehow decades of effort that
have gone there into AI architecture development, setting up
benchmarks, and in particular, setting up data sets
that can be used. And the challenge we face
or the difficulty we face in biology is just
on a different scale and on a different level.
So we all know that we need to have a multimodal profile of a patient to
understand the underlying biology.
On the other hand, we never have a data set where we actually have all modalities
available. We are collecting more and more multimodal data sets, but then we have
those of very few patients.
So in our setup of benchmarks and models
and model design, I think we really need to come to the realization
that we need new architectures that are suitable for the
data structures that we have that are just very different what we had so far,
and that our benchmarks need to be very particular.
SoIf we ask questions, when does multimodality
help? Or which modality helps us to ask which type of
questions? We need to set up tasks that reflect that, because
if
we are operating in a space where we will have always missing data and super
unpaired levels of modalities, it is very easy to fall into the
trap of asking very simple question for which one modality
is actually sufficient to answer them.
So it's an additional exercise to really come up with
benchmarks that are hard enough and kind of reflect the clinical reality that we
have,
where you need to integrate several modalities.
I think that to say we don't have any multimodal models in
biology. So we have models that are
unimodal, and then we have late fusion schemes where we basically
have a layer that tries to integrate those modalities.
We have very little models that are really truly multimodal, that then
have also the capacity or should have the capacity to really
capture what information do we get from modality A versus
modality B, which we will probably not achieve.
And
just last comment, if we look at the evolution of language
models like GPT, they actually have moved
from rather late fusion schemes where we had an image encoder and a
text encoder, to models that are really trained
fully multimodal.
But then we have
text and we have image perfectly paired.
Also modalities that overlap fairly well, while in biology we have
modalities that capture this part of reality and that part of the underlying ground
truth, and here we have information A and here we have information B.
That requires new benchmark, new architectures, new ideas,
many things.
That's great. So Ben, you're not off the hook.
So I think one aspect of benchmarks that's often not
really talked about is as soon as a benchmark is released, it's going to be gamed
in the sense that we're going to try a lot to optimize that
benchmark and we're going to succeed.
And sometimes those successes are just pure random chance.
If you try a thousand things, one will stick.
And so a benchmark needs to evolve.
It has to have new data every time or
in a frequent basis to make sure that the community does not basically overfit
a given benchmark. And so I have a question for the panel.
If you had to choose one way to build a
benchmarks to evaluate a field, would it be that you
organize competitions or would it be that you have a completely open benchmarks
and you have those tier of data that are released over time so that you
can always have some new data to test your model on?
What would be, just one word, competition or open
benchmark?
Charlotte, what do you think?
It's hard to say. I think depends on the context.
Ah. You're a real scientist.
I feel like you would say challenge, so I'm going to say open.
Just spark some controversy here.
Okay.
I'm going to go with challenge.
Yeah, I agree. Challenge.
Yeah. So challenge are a lot harder to organize, but I think they put the
bar very, very high.
But open benchmarks really let everyone play at any
time on a dataset, but they tend to be overfitted very quickly.
Yeah. And another challenge with the open benchmarks, I think ideally it would be
fantastic, but we are struggling with these--
Not struggling, but models are coming out from companies that have
huge access to very large amounts of data and very ultimate
compute, and releasing updated version of the model so rapidly that
it's so hard to keep up to date with new
sets of
subset of benchmark datasets that are unlikely to be contaminated.
The leakage, I think is the biggest concern.
And I think this is why this is actually, I think, a problem for the global
community, is we really have to start thinking about how to do this.
And Ben and I have been in many discussions over the past few days about setting up
a challenge that would involve the international community to
do this. And that's not a actually trivial task because it depends
inherently on the data. And so I think this is a very timely discussion.
But
we see how quickly even some of the virtual cell challenges where the letterboards
were
hacked, or you can decide how you want to say that.
But I think for biomedicine, we have to think about this from a
very
systematic perspective.
But I mean that also then ultimately, I think one of the bottlenecks of virtual
cell challenges was the metrics that we are using, right?
Right.
And
so
in, I think one of the successful challenges that has probably been to
solve the protein folding team, the protein folding challenge.
So there we had, I don't know how many iterations before actually Alphafold
1 and Alphafold 2 and Alphafold 3 were submitted.
But a metric that
to some degree was, I think, faithful enough.
In biology, in single cell biology, here we are struggling a lot for the
perturbation analysis to define good metrics.
Yes.
So if we are organizing it in a challenge setup, we also put a lot
of responsibility on those
that are organizing the challenge to redefine the form of ground truth or the
metric that we are comparing against us to, which
is a research question in itself.
I was going to say that if
I wear my clinician hat, I would hope that something analogous would
also happen on AI for medical devices.
We don't have a way to benchmark what is
increasingly competitive subfields.
And you would love there to be, maybe it's not a
challenge in so much as it's a
curated
modelEnclave that
allows evaluation of proprietary
models in a closed situation. But I think that
as the preponderance of digital health tools expands, sometimes
with very little evidence in terms of efficacy, but yet
the capability of billing our insurance,
I think we should demand that for those models that actually include AI
components or a neural network or a model-based
infrastructure, that there is some accountability for those technical aspects.
So I see that in parallel to this kind of scientific
benchmarking, but I think it's also really important to keep in mind as the
community of creators of the model infrastructure.
And I wonder if we can turn to you and ask, because I think
radiology imaging, to me, seems like a great place to
start on the
clinical side because we have standardized devices, the outputs, and yet
if I talk to any of my radiology colleagues, they're like, "Oh, it's still the Wild
West. We have a new tool every day." Can you speak to your
perspective on this and where you think we're at, and if there really are
opportunities to set up the sort of gold standard data sets that we could
use for this?
Yeah, absolutely. I think in radiology, we have seen some recent
successes. In the field of radiology, there have been
actually large randomized controlled trials out of Europe
showing the benefit of AI-assisted
mammography screening. That's the real gold standard.
If we can hold these models to the same bar that we hold
new management strategies to and show that it actually improves a hard patient
outcome, that's what we ultimately want to see.
Now, of course, the models are advancing much faster than we are able
to run clinical trials, and we already have this very resource-constrained setting
where it's difficult to run trials, even
a new registration trial. It's just not going to be feasible to run
large randomized trials for every different
AI model.
For radiology, I think, starting in settings where you
have what is as close to the next gold standard as
possible in cancer is paired imaging and
tissue biopsy is a good place to start.
There are differences in how pathologists
might
make diagnoses based on an H&E slide,
but it's fairly close to gold standard.
Now, in radiation oncology, we're actually using AI quite a bit.
We're using it for automated treatment planning and tumor auto segmentation,
which is where we contour targets
and normal tissues and use that to plan our radiation beams.
The
auto contouring, which is now widely rolled out for
normal tissues in treatment planning systems,
we don't have very large benchmarking strategies, but it
is considered fairly low risk. It has received quite a bit of
uptake. Interestingly, there is not a lot of evidence showing that it
provides value to the clinic or to the patient.
We did a very small randomized controlled trial where
we looked at using
AI-assisted heart contouring for breast planning and
just wanted to see if it improved the efficiency of our radiation
planners. And in fact, it didn't, which is really surprising.
But people are using it anyways. It probably reduces cognitive
burden and hopefully could, at minimum,
help address the challenges with burnout,
which downstream has effects on patients because then the more
clinicians burn out, the less access to care they have.
Similar with radiation planning, we don't have a lot of existing
benchmarks, and this is a setting where it'd be very
difficult to create a real human benchmark because where we're
using the radiation auto planning most frequently is in
daily adaptive treatment where we're adapting
the radiation plan, and we need AI to do that because there is no way that
a human could do it
in a short enough time that a patient could lay on the table waiting for the plan
to be ready. And so there, there are trials going on
to see if this approach does either reduce the toxicity or improve
efficacy.
But to follow up on your point,
we're never going to have enough resources to run trials for all the AI
tools we want to deploy in the clinic.
So
we're going to need benchmarks that are fast to run in
many, many cases, probably the vast majority of cases.
So my question for the panel is,
should we
let every institution build their own benchmark?
Should we get an institution like ACR or ASCO or
both to be the broker for those benchmarks, or
should we let the FDA or Health Canada or whatever the equivalent in
Europe and Asia to set those benchmarks so that they can
approve the tools with metrics they
trust and value? It's an open question for the panel.
I'll take a stab.
I guess I'd argue the analogy in
current anatomic pathology is that every institution
currently develops their own benchmark.
A CLIA certified lab-developed assay is one where an
institution can show
equivalency to an existing benchmarked and
gold standard method, and then use that and bill it to insurance.
And I think that that model is one that regulatorily
seems currently too applicable to AI models,
candidly. And also, I think is feasible for deployment, where you
have some sort of maybe central evaluation of models
by
a
By an honest broker
entity that is able to
adjudicate the performance of the central model, and then the model could be
fine-tuned to institutional idiosyncrasies to help
mitigate drift or biasing components
based on specific hardware, for example.
So that's my two cents, that we can borrow from the pathology community
and
use that kind of existing trustworthy infrastructure for adaptation.
What do you think, Danielle?
Yeah, I think it's a really good question. It's a hard question.
I
think we should certainly allow institutions to create their own benchmarks that
they feel is fit for purpose for their institution.
But
it
isn't sufficient because the smaller institutions, even
large institutions, are already struggling and will increasingly struggle
to build up the infrastructure to
oversee and evaluate all those strategies.
So I think
at minimum to ensure that we have fairly equitable
access to technologies, it would be ideal to have an
independent
broker play a
role in evaluating at least the medium or higher risk
AI models. Now, who should that be? It's really hard to say.
Is it the FDA? Is it the NCI? Is it a professional
society? I don't know the answer to that.
Likely, I think the best would be a collaboration between
the professional societies and regulatory bodies, and it's going
to require quite a bit of multidisciplinary
collaboration, perhaps more than we've seen previously with
regulatory approaches, because
you need quite a bit of deep data science and computer science expertise
paired with clinical expertise to design these types of benchmarks, and I don't
think we have the expertise sitting in one body alone.
I'm not the right person to answer, so just two thoughts.
In the machine learning community, it has been mostly community-driven, right?
So this has actually been initiatives
by
labs that has been picked up and continued and really
evolved into community efforts. And I think that's great and actually the
most valuable resource for research, because then also everybody can
contribute and advance. If we are talking about models that are
supposed to be in a deployment or enter the clinic, I think
here we are opening a completely different box of what
benchmarking even means, because we are actually entering a
field where we not only need to assess performance, but also risk and
bugs and how can a model be hijacked and what form of
hallucinations. And so here benchmarking actually also means to
understand what are the constraints and the limits of the model, and
we actually have no clue on how to do that in the first place.
So I think for research purposes, understanding what the
models are capable of purely in performance, it is probably actually
valuable to keep this also an open effort that everyone can
contribute in the machine learning community with open publishing and
open contributions and open source.
It has been, I think, one of the most successful strategies.
But there, the deployment has never been as close, right?
As what we are facing now in the clinic and in cancer research.
I think it's a very interesting discussion because it really illuminates that there
are many stakeholders involved in this, and increasingly, as you point out,
some of these
apps are being pushed even towards patients, right?
So, as we have more of a consumer health component to all
of this, that changes the calculus as well, and I think the
whole message here is,
first of all, it's clear we are not all the way there with the research, so we have
to continue that community effort.
And I think the more open source it can be, the greater trust
we will probably all have in it as well.
I think there's an issue of trust and transparency,
reproducibility, traceability of what we're doing and seeing how we're
improving. So I think on the research side, we have to have that, and I think
we actually need a research component to continue to fuel what's happening
clinically because the data, the models are shifting.
But there we also need some regulation, right?
And figuring out the risk benefit, I think, is so important because
there's arguments that you could say in very low-resource environments, we have
none of these tools, and gosh, wouldn't it be better to be
closer to the right-- There's an argument to be made about how we
deploy any of this, and I think that's one of the really exciting
applications of AI to democratize it.
But if we get it wrong, if it's biased or otherwise, we know it can
also induce harm. So it's a really, I
think,
pivotal time for the field to think about this, and I think it will take the
academic
communities as well as the professional societies, regulatory
bodies to think on this. And we all
perhaps have a role in shaping that future.
Yeah. I really like the comment on open community.
I think we have a lot to learn from the computer science community, but our risk is
different, so we're going to have to probably have a hybrid solution.
So I would like to pause here for a second or two.
If there are any questions in the audience, don't hesitate to
stand up and go to the microphone.
Any questions online?
No, there are no questions online.
So yeah, go ahead.
Hello.
Correct me if I am wrong, but I got the impression that there are
many foundational models out there developed by individual
companies, individual institutions, universities, et cetera.
Do we need one
model for biomedical research
... developed, trained with the best data, the cleanest
data,
maybe by a public consortium like
the human genome was back in the day?
Do you think we need one model instead of so many?
So do we need one model to rule them all?
It's right now.
Yeah. There is so much overlap on the panel. I think we only need one of us.
So no, it's a valid question in terms of
investment, right? In pathology,
Alex, how many foundation models are there in pathology?
So many. So many.
Can you count them?
Probably like-
15 good open source-
Yeah
... foundation models. So yeah.
But there is also a concept in computer science, which is there is no free
lunch. So not a single model can always win.
But there is a trade-off. As a community, do we keep
investing in building those, let's say,
pathology foundation models, or do we create coalition, or do
we let it loose and let model Darwinism operate?
So maybe we can have perspective from the whole panel.
In the end, it's a decision of everyone else if they want to build another
foundation model, right? I think ultimately,
probably we get to a realization in which domains are we pretty good, and we should
always have several models because there will be just not one model that kind of
fits all purposes. So there will always be multiple models.
And then,
I think at some point, everybody realizes that it's somehow time to move on.
Okay, so we've been pretty good at H&E models, and even there we are
probably not at the end, right? But how can we integrate other spatial aspects?
And so I think it's very natural that the community moves to the most exciting and
most challenging questions.
Okay.
Yeah. No, I agree. I think at some point, it becomes also diminishing returns.
And I think the question that many people have, and we could have maybe a thread
about this if it's of interest, but
the sort of trade-offs in terms of fine-tuning models for particular tasks that
we might want to use them for. I think we don't really have
fully multimodal models the way we all would envision them because we
don't have multimodal data the way we would dream of.
So then it becomes a wonderful question of
how much gain or bang for buck do you get from additional modalities.
We had some of this in our session in this very same room just a few hours ago.
So I think lots to be contemplated there.
Maybe just one more remark.
In this AI virtual cell paper that we wrote two...
or a year and a half ago, we actually had a section.
Will there be one AI virtual cell? And the answer is no, because there will be
private instances and public models, right?
And so there we already kind of came to the conclusion that
also for different components, there will be multiple model, which then makes
it also more challenging to, of course, build models that integrate many
aspects because we have many different model choices.
But
yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. I agree with everything that's been-- I guess I'll answer from a more social
perspective.
I think it's
beneficial
for the community and for society to have
a multitude of models being developed and
many groups pushing towards advancing the next model
iteration.
Creating a single model, even if it's kind of housed within
a fairly
neutral broker, I think is a fairly
potentially dangerous situation.
So I think, as much as we can encourage
open models where possible, that's not possible with a lot of
private protected health data.
And many different communities building models, the better,
both in terms of making sure the models become better and better over time
and ensuring that everyone continues to have
access to well-performing models.
I'll say one other opportunity I think for
us as a community is that the foundation models that do exist have, by and large,
not been intentionally designed, right?
They are
compiled out of institutions of convenience, and they are
not designed to represent the most common ways where
data may be acquired in future instances.
And so this is really-- I think this is a challenge because when we think
about deployment,
the majority of data passed through a foundation model may be
technically out of domain because it hasn't been collected on the right microscope
or it hasn't been processed with the right
capture technology in the operating room.
So I think there is opportunity for us as a community to say, if we're going to
invest in some additional foundation model development, what are
the points of metadata that need to be
represented in the model development?
And Caroline Chung really
talks about this a lot, and I think it's a really good point to think about.
What are the components, what are the elements
that will be reflected in the encodings from a foundation model that
need to be built representatively over the
population of anticipated future deployment?
And I think those components, as well as the model architecture size and
scope, are not currently
built into the model joint development.
I'll be the cynic in the room. As long as journals publish them, there will
be more.
So question from the audience.
Thank you very much. Excellent panel.
I have a question for which I don't have an answer.
I'm wrestling with the question. I'd love to hear your thoughts.
I recently updated my phone, and the first thing that Android asked
me is, do you want to connect MyChart?
Do you want to connect CVS, Walgreens, your Apple Watch,
all the other things? So it basically started asking if I wanted to have
all my data as a patient centralized inside the
Android platform. Which reaches about two billion people, right?The
second question was: who do you want me to give access to?
I have access to Anthropic Healthcare,
ChatGPT Health, and it asked me, "These yes, these no."
So the question for the panel is, in this new environment that it
looks like Android is deploying.
And basically where they are giving the patient a
key for the data vault. Which we said it's a
key component. What do you think are the new opportunities for us
as a community?
Thank you.
Well-
I don't have the answer.
I'll start. As a physician, I will say, I'm
going to try not to name any names. But let me just say that the worst
part of my clinical job is interacting with my current electronic health
record provider. And so I imagine this
future state where,
on behalf of my patients, their raw clinical data,
their imaging, their pathology, raw
images, their lab values, and the
audio recordings of our conversations are all dumped into a central
personalized repository that is capable of
analyzing
multimodal data through some large transformer architecture.
And
the data exists and is passed in real-time to me and
to my patient so that we can have an informed
conversation. And so that we obviate the need of this
incredibly cumbersome
intermediary step, which is our current proprietary
electronic health record systems,
and allows us a much more free flow of information.
So my side, the privacy, the security
concerns are substantial. But the upshot for utilization
and as a medical provider, what I see as the future potential
would be transformative in terms of my
day-to-day quality of life.
So maybe I can follow up on that. But I think Daniela, you
should answer as well in terms of clinic first, maybe.
Yeah. I agree with everything you said.
I think there is
something Ken Mandl at Boston Children's Hospital talks about a lot.
There's a lot of potential, and I think I find it hard to
argue for a reason that it shouldn't be the patient who really
primarily owns the data, and
with appropriate disclosure to them and
education to them about the risks of what it means to share your data with
other entities. Everyone should have the choice on how to share their data.
Of course,
providing data to the
frontier model companies does,
as Alex, you just mentioned, carry risk.
And I do worry that's not being
adequately communicated to the population, what it
really means to share data
with
these proprietary models.
That said, I think there's huge potential,
as long as the data doesn't
in another way become locked up by another
one or two companies. And I think that's where we, as a community,
have a lot of power both in educating the population, educating patients, and also
pushing for regulation that ensures
that data that's being collected on patients, there's a
way for that also to contribute to the public good.
Because there is a long history in public health that there is a sense of
patients own their data, but there's some shared ownership because they also
benefit from
research and healthcare services.
And there is some ethical,
in some ways, requirement that some of that data be shared to
further help the next generation of patients.
And I do fear that if
the
data sharing becomes overly privatized and
industrialized in that way, we might lose the benefit
of the real-world evidence that we might otherwise
be able to benefit enormously from,
if realized properly.
So I'll say a few controversial points of view here.
We discussed the danger of basically there is no danger in the
patient owning the data, but there might be a danger that not only the risk are
not properly disclosed when you share your data, and you also have companies
building those platforms that are kind of locked up.
However, I don't think the current system is actually that different.
We lock up data in our hospital databases.
We make it, in effect, quite difficult for patients to get all their
data.
So if I really want to be
cynic again,
you could say that hospitals are actually playing that role right now.
And
sometimes very stupid paradoxical things happen.
It's easier for me often to, instead of
signing a data transfer agreement for another institution, it's
easier for me to put the data publicly so that my collaborators can grab them.
And so unless we optimize the way we share information
across institution and with the patient, it's going to be very hard to
argue against the fact that maybe patients should be the
brokers. But it opens another can of worms.
There are many, many risk associated to that.
But I really feel that the system we have today
is kind of broken, and it's not super obvious how to
fix it, in my opinion.
I just want to reflect on a conversation I had actually with a patient
survivor at this meeting who said when we're talking about ways that we
couldBring together data that have been behind firewalls
across continents and has fundamentally hindered
discoveries for rare diseases. And this patient
had one of those rare diseases and said, "Okay, how do we build something
that would be patient-forward, where patients are basically the brokers?"
And I said, "Well, this person's actually very creative." And so,
we started brainstorming about what it would take for that to look like.
And in fact, there are some examples.
And if some of you may know Cory Painter, who set up the Count Me In project at
the Broad. This is an effort where patients can say, "I contribute, I open consent.
Here's my data." It is publicly available for others to mine.
My lab has used those data. I'm sure many others have.
And, there are examples of this. And
so, I think many of you probably haven't heard of that, which also says,
how do we think about what it would mean to scale this?
And it's not just
it's the genomics, it's the healthcare data, it's the scale of what one could
achieve if data were shared in that manner.
And I think the other piece is,
for a lot of these other datasets, the issue that you're mentioning is, well, data
were collected through the routine course of patient care, and patients didn't
necessarily provide a consent for it to be used.
So a lot of this is about how data is being used and how we sort
of come back to the system and ask, what are the needs?
And I think there's also perhaps lack of
appreciation that we can
develop very powerful models, and I would like us to spend some time on
architecture at some point. We should come to this next.
But we can build these very powerful models, and they're only as good as the
data we input to them. So if data is rate-limiting for
oncology, for a disease that evolves continuously, for which we very seldom
have repeat measurements,
and we want to do better, we want to predict, we want
to forecast, which can be done, and be more anticipatory for patients, and maybe
even intervene before overt disease, well then we need
a very different approach to what we're doing perhaps today.
There's a question. Yeah. Hello, Mike.
So I think to follow up on that, and I think the conversation came
up in one of the sessions today or yesterday of who's going to pay for it,
right? I think our institutions are all advising
us to keep our models and our data and our images
in-house, right? Because there's tremendous value to these models
that can be capitalized on, right?
And our institutions are doing this because they're fighting to survive, right?
There's not a great funding climate, there's not an initiative
to pay for that.
So I think
in the need for us to share data and to share models
that have enormous capital value, who's going
to pay for it? And how do we do that?
This is a very poignant point, and there's a lot of discussion about this,
including from our new NCI director this week.
I guess I want to come back to just a point that absolutely data
have been likened to oil, gold, whatever you
want to say. But as Alex pointed out in the beginning, the
value is decreasing in some realms.
And so maybe we can follow up on that point and talk a little bit about
what that means in the context of these kinds of foundation models, where they're
there, and then actually, guess what? I didn't need that much data anymore, right?
So I think it's...
Yeah, I think it's a great point, and it's a really challenging one for
leadership to make this calculus, right?
At the beginning of the, let's say eight years ago, at the beginning of the AI
revolution, data was incredibly undervalued, right?
The institutions that had made investments in digitization stood
to benefit substantially from those investments.
And I think there are some really well-publicized
public instances where
licenses for huge volumes of data were made at
much below the value of that data in terms of the
commercialization potential. And now we're seeing the pendulum swing in the other
direction, where some of those, in some cases, some of the
same players are seeing investments
devalue substantially versus their
peaks. And part of that is because the
access to the data is
much more open. And so I think these same sorts of
economic boom-bust cycles are going to happen for a variety of
different data modes as we collect them.
And my intuition is that
institutions right now are still a little bit behind
and are thinking that their data is more valuable than they are, than it is.
And they are. I'm getting the noun clause wrong now.
And I think it's very challenging to think about
what are the combination,
maybe the value of an institution's data is still higher if
the demographics that they represent are unique, right?
This moding concept or
can you build models with that data that are more generalizable, for example.
So it's a really challenging-- it's a great question and a really challenging
scenario currently just because the field is
moving... The economics behind the field are moving very
quickly in parallel with the technology expanding rapidly.
Yeah.
Not the researchers. The clinician's going to pay for it.
You guys have tons of money. We don't.
Would you agree, Charlotte?
So, do you still have a question or is it a new one? Sorry.
I think you were first.
There's also one over there.
Oh, gosh.
Thank you. Sorry.
Hi, thank you so much for this panel.
So my question has a little bit
of a different track. But I've noticed in AI and biology, we borrow a
lot from computer science. Like over the talks the last couple of days, people
often compare their models to GPT.
But obviously, like you guys have talked about, biology and computer science are
very different. We don't have the vast amounts of data.
We don't have this multimodal data.
And you've already talked about how benchmarking needs to be different when it
comes to biology or cancer. But I was wondering if you could talk a little bit more
when it comes to designing model architecture when you're coming up with these
models and actually doing that, how we need to start thinking differently than
computer scientists might because of the unique challenges of our field.
Charlotte?
That's the focus of my lab and what we are thinking of.
So I can give you a couple of examples
just to understand all the modules that we can think of.
So on the one hand, we've built those large foundation models.
The core entity that goes in is tokenization.
And so that is the very first part where we need to think how do we tokenize all
the modules and all the entities that we feed into our model.
And then if you go at the very end of a model, like the learning objective,
we've understood now that training our models
without annotation actually has a lot of benefits.
So one of the aha moments I had in my own career was
looking at those large vision transformers that have been trained on
Instagram scale data, without any
supervision, outperforming models that had been trained to classify foreground
from background and actually being better because by not having
this very particular distinct task in mind, they've actually
learned patterns in the data that are much more generalizable, and then you take a
new data cohort and you actually outperform those specialized
models. But then the question is, what is the learning
objective, the learning signal we give?
If we just look at imaging, there's multiple.
We can mask, we can contrast. We can generate, we can
do a combination of those.
If we are looking at masking and we are looking at tissue data, is masking really
the strategy? If I mask a T cell, is there any signal for the
model to fill it in? Probably not. And then we have
so many different angles. It's not that we just train a language model where it's
all about text. We have so many models at the same time.
So we need to innovate, starting from
the level of tokenization all the way to the learning objectives that we are
designing and
the learning schemes that need to deal with unpaired data, as we already mentioned.
So, that's exactly the exercises, and that's why a lot of
money actually needs to also flow into AI development.
Not only into data collection efforts, but also really
consortia that concentrate on developing those tools and
those methods the same way
we funded computer science research.
So that's absolutely a critical component.
Then very last part is that a lot of
components are really focusing about agents.
Agents are great tools to bring a
language into the game, have an easy way to
interact with the models that we might be building.
But then at the same time, so far, they're mostly
automating or
standardizing or giving us an access to those models.
In biology, we need more because we have no language access
to the data. We don't know what we see. We don't know what to interpret.
We have no reasoning traces. So that's another challenge.
We need clearly agent interfaces, but then our current agents are
just more sophisticated tool callers.
They cannot integrate with the foundation models that we've built.
And then we can't really prompt our models because we simply don't
know what they're supposedly capturing because we don't know the ground truth, we
don't know the underlying biology, we don't know the mechanisms.
So also here, a huge amount of tasks that
have to be solved.
I guess I'll just add to say, I think you hit on it, Charlotte, but I think one
thing that the community really needs to spend time thinking about
is this complexity of biology and giving
a biological framework in which we can reason because
it is not human language, to your point.
And we know that for some of the tasks of performance,
like mathematics, giving a mathematical
framework to how you think about deploying these
kinds of existing AI tools actually improve
performance quite substantially because they had a
system in which to operate. There is no such system
yet for biology, and I think that's actually what has to be built,
and we have to think about different architectures.
And, I think there's also the revolution that's already happening
in the broader AR community around thinking about world models, not
simply large language models, and how do
we relate that to the questions we have.
And maybe one other piece that we haven't talked about, it's
a bit distinct here, but as we get towards evaluating
then our frameworks, we have to think about uncertainty quantification
and what
that is. So we're back to actually a lot of good old statistics in its new
form in this context, and this is why there's so much need
for development. Then what are the
metrics and perhaps even independent data to
evaluate performance of these new approaches?
Yeah. So I'm not a computer science, so I
can't speak too much to the architecture.
I will say, one thing kind of coming from the NLP
side of things is I was initially kind of surprised
when, okay, we had the BERT models, which are kind of the
predecessors of the large language models, slightly different architecture, but
similar to the GPT models,
really kind of outperformed a lot of baselines from the previous NLP
methods. And then we got the GPT models, and it was like, wow.
When I first saw the GPT-3
output,
looking back now, I would think it wasn't that impressive, but honestly, I couldn't
believe my eyes. But it kind of makes sense that language
models are what got us this kind of initial, really
impressively performance models because language is how we communicate knowledge
and reason. So it's almost already--
there's a lot of abstracted knowledge that's easy for a model to learn when you
train it on text.
I don't have a reason to believe that the transformer architecture should
work similarly across modalities.
That being said, it is impressive how well the transformer
model does seem to be able to generalize.
So I think, as we get more data and we have it
paired with benchmarks-Maybe pre-specifying the
architecture will matter less and less and less,
but clearly we're not there quite yet.
I think I'll say one other thing that I think is a big opportunity for us is that
at its base, for example,
DinoV2 architecture
pushes
data into the feature space in a way that
intentionally
destructs some of the elements that
relate to density of data,
a likeness of data. It generates a well-posed
feature space. And so I think there's also, if we're thinking about
models that can help us understand biology, I think it will
also be helpful to develop
actual architectures that allow us to understand where the
knowledge gaps are. Because I think that there's this
assumption that when you feed a model enough data, it is
representative of all reality, and therefore it fills a space that
is reflective of that reality. And I think that's
making some critical assumptions, particularly with intrinsic factors of biology,
that is maybe a bridge too far.
Maybe just one more comment. I think that's actually a very nice thought.
Then there's, of course, also the ability of using the generative
process
skill to
use it as a learning signal, or if we are talking about multimodal models, if I'm
able to go from one modality to the other, do I have actually learned
underlying biological rules that are good enough to make my model a
generalist model? But this is all to be proven.
Maybe I'll say one more thing.
More data is not always the best. We discussed about diversity.
My prediction is that in five years, 50% of internet is going to be AI slop.
So there is a real question about data
quality that's probably going to come up, because in the future, we'll have
10 millions of whatever data types, but the truth is, it could be
half of data you don't really need,
and that could make the model worse.
So I'm wondering if it's going to be an agentic system again, or whatever, but
we're going to have to be able to
be quite selective to make sure that we gather the essence, and
we explore that space efficiently.
And it could be that some data just don't exist and active learning kind of
paradigm where you would ask the model, as you said, Charlotte,
"What is the next space that I need to
explore to really maximize the return on investment in terms of data
modeling?"
So question over there?
Oh, no. That was my question. Thank you.
I think in the middle.
Oh, great. Sorry.
Thanks, Christina. Thank you all for your time tonight.
I want to ask more about the agents.
I think that they could be very valuable in research, but I also think that
we've already seen that there are misuses of agents in science.
And so in terms of scientific integrity, each person has a
responsibility to use agents properly and check on their work.
But as PIs and as attendings, that responsibility is
ultimately yours. So I would like to ask how each of you are thinking
about setting standards for agent use in your labs and in your
clinics to guarantee that scientific integrity over time.
That's a good question.
She's asking.
Or Sophie.
No, no. Go, go ahead.
No, maybe we start.
It's such a good question that nobody wants to start.
I can start, and it is really challenging.
We
don't have any true agentic uses
running in clinic
as a part of
actual clinical care delivery, depending on how you define agentic.
We're using LLMs, and maybe there's some simple tool calling behind
it.
For clinical settings right now, they're all assistive, in which case
the liability is ultimately on the clinician, and so it really is still on the
clinician to review and make sure everything's correct.
There's major issues with automation bias and
over-reliance, and then ultimately, probably, likely de-skilling,
that we haven't really
completely filled the gaps in yet.
I think there's going to be a lot of work on it, and I believe interface
design and a lot of new innovations that might not be
on the modeling side, but more how do we help humans be
effective and vigilant overseers of AI when used as part of
clinical care. But ultimately, if in an assistive setting, you can assume it's
going to be the clinician who's liable if there's an error.
As things become more automated, I believe that
the more automated the method is,
then there should be some responsibility and accountability that
shifts towards the developer, and that will also push the developers
to create the best and safest model possible.
Without having any accountability and responsibility, we're going to really
plateau at the performance of these clinical models, I believe.
From the research setting, this is not fancy, but the way that I've
been addressing it is I have basically a kind of written
down
standards of practice for my lab of when you can use
AI and when you can't use AI. I do allow my lab to use AI
for coding assistance, as long as they're able to
understand the code that is being developed.
But
for writing,
my bar is you can use it for copy
editing and grammatical assistance, but not to generate
any primary content.
Yeah. I think something similar. I'll agree with you
on the clinical side. We
also don't use any specific agents.
And on the research side, I think we have a similar...
Basically, the bar is, in my lab, that every sentence needs to
be principally humans
constructed.I'll tell you though, that on
the code side,
the week that
Claude Code with Opus 4.6 came out, I didn't sleep for
three nights because I was like, "What
just happened?" The first student
sent me his work for the week, and it was a 38-page LaTeX document.
And I was like, "What's going on right now?"
And then the second early adopter
had something analogous and was like, "Oh, I looked at these
massive set of parallelized experiments." And then I was like,
"Listen, everyone in the lab is getting as many tokens as you can consume."
And I had a small
account that a benefactor had given our lab, and I was
like, "We're going to
go as hard at as much
Claude Code as we can consume to co-design a couple of
months' worth of experiments." And I viewed it as an
existential change in the
way that productivity was developed.
And I also had to change the way I evaluated students' work because I now
can't look through all of the work all of my students do each
week. I'd estimate an 8X
increase in productivity per student.
And so now I
have resisted having an agent that reads my
students' agentic output because then we're in the
slop wars, right? Where just-
Don't do that.
Yeah.
So
now they have this huge portfolio of work and I'm like, "Well,
tell me what the most exciting results were in
your own human words and distill it for me what the
results were so I can ensure that they're understanding the
overall components." But that was what?
End of February and end of January.
It completely changed the outlook that I had for
how my lab team structures were going to be for the foreseeable future.
So it's an excellent question to ask and one that has made
me tachycardic just thinking about it.
Maybe just two anecdotes. So I think that that hiring
cycle, I was interviewing a PhD student who came from a pre-doctorate
program of one of the frontier labs working on one of the frontier LLMs, and
I asked him about his coding practices.
And he basically said that there's
nobody ever coding anymore, or it seems very limited, at least
he doesn't, because there's so many subteams within this frontier lab
competing against each other, who's not coding with agents, right?
At the same time, if we look at the recent studies that have been done at the
leading AI conferences, NeurIPS, ICML,
the problem that we have with hallucinated citations, right?
We clearly know these models have massive flaws.
A lot of papers that were desk rejected because of
fraudulent activity. So I also see students
being more productive, but there's pieces that those models cannot
do, creative forming certain core
elements of a model, or then the efficiency might be increased here,
but then it drops there. It can also slow down the workflow, and I think
that's, as a PI, actually quite hard to somewhat manage.
And it's a skill for every student and everyone to
acquire, like how do I use the model so that they actually make me more productive
versus less productive, right? When sometimes we are prompting them and prompting
them again, and in the meantime, I might have just written it myself.
So...
And you make the great point that that kind of critical reasoning can't be
replaced. And we are still at a point where we mostly
have students who at least went through their undergraduate education
without access to these coding models.
Soon we're going to start having students who have gone through their entire
education with agentic assistance
broadly and specifically right now, especially coding.
And that's where I worry we're going to start seeing a real gap in their
ability to oversee anything and to ask
interesting research questions.
I don't know what the term is. Is it deskalization?
Descaling.
Yeah. So
I think to follow up on Alex's point,
the speed at which you can prototype and test an idea
has exploded. It's like 100 times now, right?
That doesn't mean that that should be your end product.
The way I see AI is that I prototype
and then you need to kind of rethinking from scratch.
You can still use AI to kind of distill that code,
but in something I agree with Daniela, like something you would understand that you
can own, that you can take responsibility for.
But that's romantic. In the future, we're going to build
those huge black boxes
that are millions of lines of code with optimization we barely understand.
And I think that's where it becomes a little bit tricky, is that I think we're
going to spend more time building unit testing, positive and negative controls,
to kind of see whether that black box does actually what
we think it does,
rather than going to the code line by line and take ownership for it.
So we are in a transition period. I also agree with the...
My kids were born with ChatGPT. So the way
they learn is with those LLMs. They don't
even ask me to
help balance their homework. They say, "Oh, Dad, you know nothing.
I'm going to ask Gemini to teach me that concept."
And I think they're going to be born with it.
And so the question is not should they use it or not, but rather how do you make
sure that they have this
symbiotic synergy that's really maximal,
but they can still take ownership and responsibility and
accountability for what they generate through those tools?
Mm-hmm.
I think this is such an important discussion that's going to continue
to evolve and
It hearkens to the need for a
human still in the loop. We are still very much needed.
And to your point about, for clinical applications, how do we
maintain that accountability and where do we get the boost?
What is the greatest gain, right? Whether in terms of
efficiency or upskilling. Upskilling is what we should be looking for, right?
And I think the concern is we may very much lose these skills.
So I think the clinical versus the research side, but actually, it applies there
too, right? You
spend enough time with this, people lose their ability to sort of sit there
and code.
Which, maybe we have greater ambitions that we need to focus on, but I think the
scientific reasoning, the questions, the understanding very much remains
human at this point. And maybe we'll see that AGI moment.
I don't know. For the questions I'm asking,
this is not a full solution, but boy, wow,
I feel like suddenly I might be not quite as efficient as the students in my lab,
including Sophie, who asked the question, but maybe they'll let me play with them
again.
So, it's crazy
times, and I think the same for the next generation.
Watching my own kids, it's like, oh my goodness.
I have philosophical debates about what that all will look like.
What is the term? Anthropocentric.
I think your view is very human-oriented.
I'm not sure human is going to be needed at some point, but if we want to
work for our own sake, I would rather involve me in some
processes so I can keep some purpose.
Question over there.
Thank you.
I think on the right mic.
Yeah. Hi. Thank you for the interesting panel.
I guess we are landing on the benchmark part as one of the main conclusions,
but also thinking
back to the research community, I was wondering your
thoughts about how we ensure that the community has a
shot in reproducing all these models, or at least trying
to improve them and push the field forward.
I'm thinking on the biology side, too.
So how do we democratize the
fact that everyone can implement and create these models?
I couldn't quite hear
it.
That's super important, right? I think one example we had is AlphaFold,
right? There's initiatives like OpenFold, who
I think up to now were able to match the performance.
And now there are some subtasks, I think it's antibody binding, but I'm not so
sure. I might not be, where we
are not able anymore to match the performance of those models.
What do we need, right? So basically, we should have those initiatives that
are able to
have powerful models that are open and make them available for the
community. This requires a lot of funding,
right? Still support of
data collection initiatives that ultimately have to be
open sourcing their data. And we are in the midst or at the
starting point of many of those, right?
So there's even more data that is currently collected from those funded initiatives
that will be ultimately released.
And then also national infrastructures.
In Switzerland, I'm training my models, and I can only train my
models of this scale because I have access to the Swiss supercomputer
that has proprietary access for researchers
from the ETH and the EPFL
universities to work on those, right?
They also have part of the supercomputer reserved for the
national weather, and then they have part of the supercomputer reserved to actually
train Apertus, which was the Swiss open source
LLM. But then there's also a lot of initiatives,
like part of the supercomputer that's open for researchers like me to train those
large foundation models in biomedicine.
So in the end, it requires public funding to computing
infrastructure that scales and keeps up
with what we have in frontier labs, and then still funding of data
initiatives that ultimately are open sourced.
And
support for projects such as OpenFold and many others that
actually have an effort of building community models
that keep up with
closed source models.
So the answer is go to Switzerland.
They have everything you need over there.
I have actually a related question
for the panel, which is very close to my heart.
So
how do we ensure
full transparency, reproducibility, and reusability
of those very large
AI models? And it's kind of related to your point in the
sense that what
makes us different, the public/academic, is that
we're scientists, we advance science, and we do it in a transparent way.
Companies don't have to do that, right?
And so what I love about OpenFold is that you
go deep dive, you try to reproduce
some of the principles that have been described with beautiful text but no code in
those kind of Google-led paper or whatnot.
And that really elevate the whole field.
So we need those initiatives. We cannot just rely on a black box that a
company is building.
On the other hand,
do you believe that agentic AI is going to make our research more
reproducible, or it's going to make it worse?
What's the panel point of view on that?
Worse.
I think, just from a fundamental
perspective, the more layers, the more
complexity we are encoding in
obscured layers, the harder it is to uncover
associations that are responsible for rendering the final results
and
any spurious results. Right? So, I mean
We have seen
a lot on foundation models, this ACR, and I think that
we know that each foundation model can encode any number of different
metadata components, which have potentials for
non-biological bias being part of models.
And then those foundation model-derived features are combined through a series of
agents who are operating through a LLM whose source code is not
necessarily available. I think the transparency
element, just without even talking about computer architectures that could
be improved for
these endpoints of
reproducibility and transparency, I think that the move is
rapidly in a direction which is opaque, opaquening.
I don't know. Is that a word? It is a word now.
It is a word now.
Opaquening, TM.
Of our understanding based on this incredible complexity that's
being combined.
Yeah. I agree. I don't see how agentic AI, unless
you...
realistically is going to make things more transparent.
There's this question of even if you're collecting all the data about all
the different tool calls and all the different interactions with the model, and you
somehow make it
available, these agents generate such an
incredible amount of content that it'd be so difficult for
anyone to review or even understand what it meant,
when you're using it for a very large scale experiment.
Now, one potential glimmer of hope I have is that,
as we move towards in the clinical setting or the biomedical setting where there
is an effort to create
valuable clinical applications that
provide
real value either by improving
patient outcomes or
even allowing healthcare institutions to bill more.
Some
applications where you show clear
return on investment, and therefore you can
link
it to requirements for transparency, for
the buyer can have, "Okay, these are my
expectations if I'm going to pay for it." These more commercial
LLM type applications that don't have this really clear return on
investment, there is
no customer who's going to push strong enough, I think, for full
transparency or reproducibility to make that a reality commercially.
I
think it's all been covered very well.
I guess there's some places where I'm very excited about agentic
workflows. Just to come back to some of that and think about places
where,
maybe to be counterculture, we want to build models that are very
challenging to parameterize, and a human being used to sit there and
crank through and think about how do we update these very large
models that might relate to human biology or cancer.
So, I personally think I'm very eager to actually
run through, and I think the traceability of such a system has a lot of merits to
say, "Okay, I'm simulating this particular disease
process. I've built the simulator.
By the way, I also get ground truth with my simulator," which is a bonus here given
all we've talked about. So what if I can agentify that and get to the
points of matching, basically evaluating those models much more readily.
So I think there are many wonderful applications
besides the gains of efficiency we just talked about.
But we do need to focus on where we achieve that and what we need
and what that needs to look like, especially if you're trying to use these
approaches to advance scientific reasoning, which is in my particular case, where
we're going for it. So, okay, and then I want to know, "Ooh. Oh, dear.
I have a human in the loop, but I've got multiple agents.
I've got agents doing all sorts of things.
Where is my gain coming from in these learnings?
How do you go back and evaluate what that information boost came from?
What data source was it, by the way, also?" Because I think to the points that were
made earlier, what we really want, if we want to accelerate scientific discovery,
is to be able to say, "Aha, this is what is missing.
This is where the greatest value gain would be, the add.
Let's go do this very complicated experiment, bad bam, and we'll update and see."
But that's going to be an iterative cycle.
Maybe we'll have fully automated robotic labs to solve that, but probably
not tomorrow. So,
where do we deploy this?
To Charlotte. More or less reproducible?
I think
the agentic workflows. I think the example of Christina, I very
much enjoyed. Actually there, we might have agents that systematically
screen something and give us traceability.
In other aspects, probably not. And sometimes I'm actually trying
to use those tools myself, and I look, I open my
pen on the right, like how did you get...
Those reasoning traces are not necessarily,
it's like, okay, this is not a path I would have taken.
So, so far,
even the traceability for very trivial task is sometimes
so flawed that the reproducibility or how you got to a result
is rather questioning me about the...
It gives me rather questions about using the end result than
confidence.
So
maybe I shared the
pessimistic view of Alex. So basically, Alex, what you're
saying is,
if you compare that to deterministic programs that
we use to design bioinformatics pipelines, et cetera,
where you know you can describe every single step,
agentic AI is a big step back. There is a lot of
stochasticity, a lot of flexibility in those system that are
probably unnecessary for many, many tasks and sometimes going to be very useful.
If you compare agentic AI with a
sleep-deprived human,
I totally agree it's a lot more-Are
reproducible. And so to Daniela's point,
there are many applications where you're going to increase the consistency because
humans are just really, really bad at this.
Maybe hyperparameter tuning is also something that we should automate.
Humans are probably not rightfully equipped to explore that in
a more systematic way.
So I think we got
one of the
plenary session
basically said agentic AI is going to make research more reproducible, and I
think it's missing that part of the equation, which is what do you mean by
reproducible? There are some processes that will be, and some
processes that will... If we start applying agentic AI for everything, we're going
to be in trouble. That's my point.
There's a good question. Yeah.
I am wondering to ask,
one thing that was already brought today is that transformational moment, like
first time you opened ChatGPT and realized that that thing was talking to
you or like I said, now, like the last
version of Claude Code, now they really generate code that work.
But my understanding is that aha moment haven't really happened in medicine or
general research yet. What's the view of the panel?
What you would like to see as, or you think is this next
aha moment in
research or medicine in general?
I'll tell you tomorrow. I mean, that's how fast the field is.
What was the question?
Oh, the question is what is going to be the next aha moment?
The same way that GPT-3.5 was like, "Oh
my gosh, every
recommendation letter I ever read is going to be AI generated." And the way Claude
Code with Opus 4.6 was like, "Oh my God, every
piece of..."
In more specifically perspective, those happens were not specific to
biomedical research.
Right.
So you mean biomedical research, what would be that thing?
I think one,
I think as a clinician,
my intuition is that every drug,
starting say three years from now, every drug
is going to be AI designed, or at least co-designed with artificial intelligence.
I think that's going to-
Three years?
Three? I mean-
Years?
Well, there's already
every new drug to the market.
And probably the biomarker with the drug.
Yeah. I mean, I-
Years?
There's already positive Phase 2 at Phase 3.
Fully designed? Fully. Parts.
No.
Parts of.
I mean the-
Designed.
Stanford University is always a little bit late. It's fine. It's fine.
Okay.
I think
we're very close. I think that the
target
still has to be evaluated by humans, but I think that
the quality of drug design is going to be...
Okay. Quality of drug design, not all the way from target discovery through to-
Well, I mean, the-
... IND-enabling studies.
I think that "Nature Biotech"
paper from Insilico Medicine was an aha moment for me, because I think that blew my
mind, like target
specification,
two synthetic molecules shown proof of principle in mice in
42 days or whatever it was.
That to me was one of those sea change moments that
the life cycle of drug development was going to change dramatically, and
that as an oncologist, we were going to have more better
drugs, which is something I definitely value. So I think that's...
Oh, you-
Oh, I'm going. It's okay. No. Oh, no. I agree.
I think Insilico has done more than
most to demonstrate this, but we still then
have to do the studies to show that we get there, and I think,
again, the biomarker piece, it's great, Ben.
Because frankly, we know that most drugs fail because they're not...
Both, for a variety of reasons, but one of which being that we haven't found the
right indication, and we don't have the patient population selected.
So I guess one thing that I do think this audience still has to take away is we
still need experimentalists to also go in and
verify these hypotheses, right? This is still absolutely a
requirement, and if you look at any of the optimization of antibody design or
whatever else, there's always an experimental component.
So I think just three years.
I'll dig in on that, and I'll say that a future aha moment will
be what we can learn from the first failed study of an
AI-developed drug. Because we haven't had...
I think the
hype in the space is because the first Phase 2
was a positive study with the
AI design drug, and it'll be interesting to see why they fail.
How about that?
Behind all good AI design drugs, there is a human.
For now.
So maybe one last round for the panel. We're almost at time.
And it's going to be a tricky question, but
what do you think, what would be the most exciting
thing that could happen in your research program?
If you had infinite amount of resources and you get this great
team of geniuses working for you 24/7.
I'm not talking about agent, I'm talking about real humans here.
What do you want to accomplish in, let's say, the next three
years?
It's all happening in three years, apparently.
Yeah.
Well, honestly, I'm a physician scientist and an incremental pragmatist.
So, I would love to see, I think the promise of physician scientists
is to get your discoveries into the practice of
medicine and to the
benefit of patient care. So I would love to see biomarkers that
have been, for example, a diagnostic device that had been
developed in either in my lab or in collaboration, see
its way into routine use. With
all the hype
aside, I think that most of medicine crawls along
with very slow incremental progress, and I think that
that'sPart of how I've designed my own research strategies in order to
feasibly achieve that realistic and optimistic goal,
as opposed to thinking about a massive disruption in what
is a very
high-friction environment, which is clinical medicine.
Yeah. I would say for me, a lot of my work is focused on how can we use AI
to improve the quality of evidence that we generate from clinical
data. So what I would really love to see is that we really
start
completely change how we document on our
patients from a very passive process and a note-based
process to a proactive process where
we're collecting data iteratively and refining,
and
using AI to insert it into real
clinical practice to identify, okay, you have an underspecified piece of
information, physician, can you please ask more
questions and that can get us to a more specific
understanding of what's happening to the patient right now?
Maybe you should order this test to get us to a more specific understanding of
what's happening to that patient right now.
I think that's currently our real gap to this big
data promise and learning health system promise that we've been working
towards for many decades. So yeah, I would say summary, use
AI to actively and proactively collect
really, really high-quality data so we have the real-world evidence we need to
maybe even start moving away from large scale randomized clinical
trial for
everything. That's maybe more than three years away.
That's cool.
Am I allowed two?
Or do I have to pick one?
It's okay. One and a half.
One and a half. Okay. One and a half. That's good.
I actually have a very fundamental question that has plagued me for
many, many years, and I still have it, and it's not solved.
So maybe my agents can help me and the clever students.
But,
what does it take to make a cancer? Across tissue types, what is the minimal
requirement for malignancy? If we knew this, we could prevent
many cancers. We could intercept.
I don't think we have that answer, and I think it's a combinatorial problem.
I do think it's solvable. So that's one.
And the other is, we have now this unprecedented
understanding on the other hand of some of the causative factors of
disease. And we in fact have new clues about how to drug what was
once frankly undruggable. But that's not due to
AI yet. That's actually due to advances in medicinal chemistry.
So I want to see those make it to the clinic and benefit the patient populations
who have been overlooked,
because it wasn't profitable enough to target them, and we couldn't.
So we'll see if we can conduct those trials in three years.
Sorry.
We are looking very much at generative AI to develop new
drugs on the molecular level. In my lab, we are looking at generative
models to forecast how would this drug actually play out in a cellular context?
How do cellular phenotypes change now we move this to the tissue level?
I think what's extremely challenging and something I would like to see is can we
actually bridge the scale? So anything that I can model on the molecular level, I
actually also able to forecast how this will play out in a cellular
phenotype,
and then ultimately in a tissue level.
And that will require also collecting actually exciting new
data sets where we have those super
high-resolution tissue screens that allow us to somewhat
map to interaction studies on the molecular level.
And then we need to have this for the same drug for the same patients
in a somewhat large scale, and then develop methods that actually go multiscale.
So I think that is something that is
to some degree feasible in a three years time and gives us
a new dimension to also then develop our
drugs in silico or largely in silico because we have actually better
models to understand how they might act in a patient context.
Dan, you have to go.
So I think you're going to help Alex win this bet about the AI drug design.
So mine would be how can we use non-invasi-- so it's going to be a combination
of technology advances and AI. How do we use non-invasive
technologies to learn everything we need to know about the tumor
microenvironment and potentially the evolution of the disease?
And right now we've shown that with radiomics we can capture some
signal. With liquid biopsy we can actually capture very interesting
unexpected signal.
But that's just the beginning. If the technologies evolve,
if the AI aspect evolves as well,
it would be amazing if we could have very repeated and very
frequent non-invasive profiling
of healthy people and patients. So that would be my dream in three
years.
And we're done.
So yeah.
All right. Well, we'd want to thank the audience for their brilliant
questions and for the exciting dialogue, and hopefully this is one that
maybe we continue because there's clearly a lot more to discuss.
Or maybe we won't all be here because it will be solved in three years,
and that would be something to celebrate.
All right. Thanks, all.
Thank you very much.